I have a ketta that my daughter wants to
plan bit of a pickle as to whether I or
if I could afford it or should I do it
how much is it going cost I'm I'm
estimating between 10 and 15,000
currently going through a divorce with
her mother and uh this is kind of being
planned by her and these are their
prices kind of the problem is is that I
have just recently actually fully funded
my six-month emergency fund technically
I can dip into that but it's an
emergency fund and this is not an
emergency number one how we Define an
emergency to actually dip into an
emergency fund is when something is
unexpected so this doesn't really
qualify is it urgent do I have to do it
like right now right now right now yeah
I guess that I guess urgent would
somewhat qualify and because there's a
date there and is it necessary right so
these are the two things so honestly
this whole thing it does not check off
all those boxes for me so no it's
technically not an emergency